[Applause]
good morning Hank it's wet hold on
Charlie invited I mean surface he's safe
what am I made of stone so I hang all
day long I've been crying of course like
everyone who's watching this and Henry
has been looking at me all day with his
head tilted to the side like do you need
a diaper change
is it opposite day do you just want
someone to hold you because I can't hold
you I'm only two foot four but I can try
to arrange for someone do you need to
take a nap sometimes when I do that it's
just cuz I need to take a nap there's a
night-night time and I'm trying to
explain to him that no it's the Chilean
miners and the Chilean President and
their families and the reunions Oh Hank
I don't know if the president of Chile
is good at being the president of Chile
but I know this he is good at being
president of the independent nation of
making me cry leg all right
in other news why am i doing my happy
dance because I couldn't do it in front
of hundreds of nerdfighters at the bean
in Chicago because I'm too socially
awkward but I can't do it in my basement
by the way I think this is what it looks
like when hundreds of nerdfighters do
their happy dance at the bean in Chicago
Hank the beckoning of lovely was just
crazy beautiful with like a thousand
people coming together with Amy Krauss
Rosenthal to welcome everything lovely
into the world also I got to meet a lot
of nerdfighters several of whom have
etched permanent reminders not to forget
to be awesome
on to their bodies and and and and one
time I came up with this idea that
romantic relationships are pretty
predictable and that each romantic
relationship has a limited set of
possible outcomes breakup divorce or
death and that therefore mathematical
formula predicting who will end a
relationship and when ought to be
possible if you know some basic facts
about the two people involved in the
relationship and then laughing the
mathematical talent to create such a
formula I wrote a novel about someone
who could write a formula like that and
had the actual formula written by my
friend Brotherhood 2.0 resident
mathematician and future state
representative Daniel Biss and then Hank
someone permanently tattooed that
formula under her arm is this real-life
Hank in other news of lovely lots of
people have been asking us why we
haven't made it gets better video the
reason for this is that I feel like
other people have said what I would say
better than I would say it so instead of
making it it gets better video I have
made a playlist called it doesn't get
better than these it gets better videos
you can find that playlist in the
doobly-doo there have been some awesome
videos and you should check
even if you aren't wondering if it gets
better which it does I mean we live in
this irreparable broken world and I
don't wish to deny reality but the
amazing thing to me is not that we
refuse to relinquish hope as a species
the amazing thing is that were right to
hold on to hope the world may be broken
but hope is not crazy for the first 17
days after the mine collapse those
miners live 2,000 feet under the ground
on two days worth of rations with no
knowledge that anyone was ever going to
come for them obviously not all stories
unhappily we don't always have good
fortune but hope gives us as a species
and as individuals what we otherwise
wouldn't have a chance all right Hank
they're about to bring out another guy
so I'm gonna go I'll see you on Friday